[Music]
this is session number 41 and
speculative fiction series and this is
somebody who I wasn't originally going
to do but we always every year now it's
become a tradition we put some of the
slots to a vote and interestingly there
were a lot of people who wanted to
wanted to talk about ROM Stoker as
speculative fiction it really does fit
in there well I not you know I myself
seen plenty of Dracula movies and
variants on that but he hadn't read
Dracula I'd also seen the crazy movie
layer the white worm that some of you
may have seen tangentially connected and
the layers and then reading the layer of
the white worm that is also a pretty
crazy novel as well it's it's quite a
thing and we'll talk about and you know
I had a chance to read a few other
stalkers things and so is it was quite
good we're talking before we began I was
able to get my hands on this essential
Stoker edited by Leonard wolf who I'm
assuming is the person who did all the
extensive footnotes some of which are
quite interesting and helpful many of
which are quite opinionated oh the
footnotes yeah yeah there's a lot of
yeah that's a good book when the
footnotes are really good so I think
that during this one what we typically
do in these sessions is we talk about
the the life and biography of the person
a bit and then there's a lot of emphasis
on the world-building that they're doing
it's worlds of speculative fiction so we
we think of to the extent that we can
about what what the world that's created
in the narrative is like and there's a
pretty rich narrative universe and
Stoker I'd say and then we talk about
philosophical themes within the
literature and usually we could off
track different points but that that's
that's quite alright I always have some
philosophical themes picked out to talk
about
usually people participating and have
some that they'll point out quite often
some of the people who have read more of
the writer than I have see if that's the
case with with Stoker or ru I'm willing
to bet that some of you have read
Dracula more more times than I have as
well so no further ado let's let's let's
jump in and talk about where this guy
came from and what he was doing
yeah really an interesting life I
haven't checked out his biography before
researching it for this but he's a you
know he's Irish born in Dublin and
apparently suffered from some disease
nobody knows what it was he just alludes
to it but he was so sickly as a child
that he had to be carried around much of
the time he was no you know again nobody
quite knows exactly what was wrong with
him but when he goes to school when he
was seven years old suddenly the illness
is gone like that so it might have been
something environmental or maybe it was
you know there was something weird
psychological going on there or there
kind of coddling him too much but he one
thing that he does tell us is that
because he was so homebound he got to
hear lots and lots of stories and and
many of these were what we would
nowadays call you know not just folk
tales but horror stories or folk tales
about the horrific ghosts and you know
other worldly beings that can do
terrible things to die maybe they told
them that you know better not go too far
they'll get you or things like that but
then he he has this transformation he he
goes to school and he suddenly becomes
quite healthy and eventually becomes
very fit becomes quite an athlete and
and some some people have speculated
about
what could be going on with this and
they they said well maybe there was some
vampirism going on or blood transfusion
but probably not you know it would have
been pretty primitive at that time we're
talking about the 1850s so I don't I
don't think so but there are stories of
people who start out as sickly children
and then through calisthenics and sort
of rough living outdoors well Teddy
Roosevelt is one Julius Caesar has
another one apparently was asthmatic
there were a couple others and
antiquities some similar kinds of
stories so you know maybe it situated
the right way the human body can can
recover from from these sorts of things
and maybe if you're coddled too much as
a child that plays a role in any case
he's he's got a fairly uneventful
childhood other than that and then he
goes to Trinity College Dublin so you
know stays in town and he will do things
in that area for for quite a while he
becomes such an athlete that he wins
prizes for weightlifting and the five
and seven mile walks so he's and from
what they said in his his stories about
him he was more of a jock than he was an
intellectual when he was in college
so that made him quite popular and he
had a good time but he does be he does
get interested in the university
philosophy society he eventually become
secretary and you know when when you
become secretary of a club that's often
like you know the first rung of the
leadership position you know secretary
treasurer vice president president right
so the next year he becomes the
president of the University philosophy
Society which still exists and they have
a bram stoker Club because he's probably
one of the most famous people who went
to their school and they that
organization started in 2011 they hold
weekly afternoon paper readings on all
sorts of topics and it's it's
you know it's one of those societies
where that was that was part of what you
did and when he became president to the
society he had to read a paper a lot of
these societies would do that you get
together you read a paper talk about the
paper then eat and drink and do whatever
you're gonna do after that he was also
the auditor of the College Historical
Society graduates eventually and when he
when he does graduate he doesn't like
dissociate from the college he's still
pretty actively involved but he also
begins working in the civil service
at Dublin Castle so he's you know I'm
doing everything in the same town and
enjoys himself quite a bit he claims
that he graduated with a degree in pure
mathematics the people who research this
say that there's no possibility that he
did that that he misremembered something
or is making something up but it's it's
it's an interesting notion
eventually he actually purchases an MA
from the college which is you know a way
to and I mean purchases made a donation
you know things were not as rigorous as
they are now and he respect and then he
winds up in in the civil service thing
it becomes this inspector of courts of
petty sessions what that means is he has
to go around and like check up on the
courts and make sure that things are
going the way they're supposed to in the
courts now I think about our courthouses
right every once in a while you get a
judge she wants to do their own thing
and if it's a you know out in the
countryside they might actually get away
with it but now we have you know social
media and you know fairly rigorous
reporting officers like this were needed
to make sure that justice actually got
done in a regular way so he's going
around and he actually will later on
write a book about them the duties of
clerks of petty sessions
in Ireland it's one of his first early
early works eventually he meets this guy
Henry Irving and Irving is going to be
really important in his his story
because Irving is a major actor by this
time Bram Stoker has been doing some
literary work like you know reviews a
common thing to do at the time was
review plays or novels as a matter of
fact you know if you want to get started
as a writer even today one way to do it
is to write reviews for something
that'll get get you attention like the
local paper or you know a blog or
something like that instead of writing
something yourself you can you've
already got somebody else has done the
creative work and then you just say
whether it was good or bad and what you
thought was good about it and what you
thought was was nonsensical so he
reviews Irving's Hamlet which is which
is playing over in Ireland at the time
and Irving had been a really big name
actor and he is going to assume a really
important role in in British acting by
taking out a theatre so he meets Irving
and they have dinner and they become
friends and friends is kind of a maybe a
misnomer a bit quite a few people think
that Irving is the inspiration for
Dracula in some respect he was
incredibly charismatic kind of a jerk
when actually not kind of a jerk
manipulative and Stoker really liked the
guy it's not clear that early what
Stoker except as somebody who had you
know provide him with adulation and and
you know perks and do work for him and
things like that so in any case in 1878
he marries this actress Florence
Balcombe and they moved to London but
they moved to London so that Stoker can
become the business
manager of Irving's Lyceum Theatre and
the Lyceum had you know it had fallen on
hard times then Irving came there he was
best known at first for this this
hundred and fifty performance run of a
play called the bells that I know
nothing about because I don't think too
many people play it anymore but
apparently it was quite popular and
Irving was known as being somebody who
could really portray stuff who could who
could change things up and I looked at
the the stuff that they actually did
play while Irving was the main lead in
the Lyceum but half of it is
Shakespearean about half of it is more
contemporary play some of it adaptations
of books or things like that so that
seems to be what the theater fareth at
that time was and you know it would it
would always be herbing in the lead
position and then whoever else he had
around him and Stoker you know as the
business manager so that means that he's
got to do all the accounts he handles
all of the touring around he's very
familiar with train schedules and this
this is a theatre that actually does go
from from place to place in Europe and
in in America he has one son Irving
Knoll Thornley Stoker born in in 1879
and in the 1880s he tours America with
Irving's theater he name meets Theodore
Roosevelt so you know too sickly guys
become very robust meeting each other he
also meets William McKinley and he meets
one of his idols Walt Whitman he talks
about Whitman in some of his
correspondence he was really quite taken
with him as a matter of fact he brings
him up in an essay that had to do with
censorship and that was published in the
nineteenth century
for general review he wrote a really
interesting essay on that and he wrote a
little bit about the USO this glimpse of
America and I'll sort of this is a
common thing for people travelling
around to do at that time you go
somewhere you take some notes you
produce a book you sell the book and
everybody knows a little bit more about
the place that you're going provided you
haven't made up some of the stuff or you
know misinterpret what's quite bad so
then he a little bit later on he's
visiting Whitby in England and that's
you know part of the setting for for
Dracula and he begins working on and
researching for Dracula at first I think
it's supposed to be called the undead
and there's there's a lot of interesting
like backstory about what went on
apparently there's there's not just
Dracula's guests the first part of the
manuscript missing which we do have got
published as a story after his death but
about a hundred pages of manuscript
missing that was supposed to be early on
and it and nobody knows what happened to
it exactly we also know that he did
quite a bit of research for the story
not a lot of research and descent into
central South European history since
birth out but a lot of research into all
sorts of other things and you see him
you know you see it reflected in some of
the characters perhaps like how van
Helsing you know knows so much about all
these different different things and can
apply all these different forms of
hypnosis and he certainly was was quite
interested in what at that time they
called alien ism nowadays we call it the
study of mental health or psychology
abnormal psychology
Renfield as an example of that in 1893
begins traveling to another location
crude at bay starts taking vacations
there he set some of his other books
there and you notice he's already
starting to write other novels the
snakes pass the waters move it's just
lots and lots of dialect you like doing
dialect writing not quite so much fun
for us to read I think unless you're
into that sort of thing because you have
to try to figure out how does this
actually sound and there's a good bit of
that in Dracula too like anytime there's
a lower-class character they always have
a dialect don't they
and actually Van Helsing has his own
weird way of saying everything I don't
know if it does reflect what how Dutch
people talked at the time but there's
clearly you know it's it's something and
you know these other books weren't
really that successful but they you know
they were there getting him attention
he's also writing other short stories
and things like that along the way and
then Dracula comes out in in 1897 and I
have something that's actually there's
the dates are wrong and one of these
things Oscar Wilde I should mention this
Oscar Wilde had been a friend of Stoker
for quite a while in part because Wilde
was very interested in the woman that
Stoker would eventually marry she you
know been involved with Wilde and
they're all they're all connected
together Wilde gets convicted in 1895 of
engaging in you know homosexual acts and
gets sent to do hard labor doesn't
doesn't take well to it you know it
damages him in in body and mind so by
the time that he's released in 1880 yeah
1897 he's in pretty rough shape and
Stoker now is starting to write more and
more
stuff nothing ever comes close to
dracula in terms of either popular
acclaim or quality I think it's safe to
say your rights you know miss Betty the
mystery of the sea the jewel of Seven
Stars and he's playing around with
themes and interesting ways in these
like some of the same ideas like you
know the liberated woman and and you
know what what should happen with that
or other occult phenomena and how we
should how we should make sense out of
those eventually the Lyceum Theatre
starts running into problems
it looks like Irving might have actually
blamed some of these on on Stoker as
well which you know not very nice
because from all from all accounts
Irving was a rough guy to deal with
Stoker would you know try to do
everything he could to make life easier
for him Stoker is very devoted to to
Irving and when earthing dies Stoker
writes a kind of hagiographic book about
him and he's he's really deeply upset
one one critic actually said that that
Irving may have been the only real love
relationship that Stoker had in his life
which that might be going a little far
but there's probably something to that
you know he was he seemed to have been
attracted to these to it you know at
least somebody who was very domineering
and sometimes mistreated him I guess you
could say so eventually the Lyceum is
put into receivership Stoker has to
leave at this point he's kind of
scrambling for where's the money going
to come from you know he still has a kid
a wife and he starts writing a lot more
that's one way to do it right
become a full-time writer and you know
there's some of the more interesting
pieces come out of that these rights as
personal reminiscences of
Henry Irving that would sell well you
know he's a famous actor those sorts of
things do well in our time then he
writes lady athlean which is another
novel right snowbound the record of a
theatrical touring party sort of a you
know this is what it's like getting
caught in snow in a certain way it's
sort of like a mini Decameron you know
you familiar with the Decameron so it's
it's a book this is a thing that's been
done to death at this point you have
like a bunch of people and put them
somewhere and they don't have a lot to
do in the case of the Decameron they
they're going up to get away from the
plague in italy so they're up in the
mountains and now what do you do well
that why all the time away each of us
shall tell a story alright so you know
each one tells a different kind of story
and it's a way to put a book together
that doesn't have to have any sort of
thematic unity or yeah or overarching
plot it's just a bunch of stories and
you put them in the mouth of this person
said this and this person so that's
that's essentially what snowbound is let
me of the Lady of the shroud one of the
interesting books that that I didn't
want to check out I looked at the the
just the table of contents some of the
famous imposters and again you think
well why did he write a book like that
because it would sell you know it's the
sort of like when we were when I was
young there was this Ripley's Believe It
or Not that would come out every so
often and you know most of us probably
made up nonsense with some facts thrown
in and something some have been inflated
but they would sell like hotcakes there
was even a TV show for a while hosted by
Jack Palance Ripley's Believe that's
right yeah yeah was that in the was that
in the journal or is it only in the
Chicago Tribune though I think I
remember reading it and in the Tribune
because my grandpa would get the Tribune
but it wasn't in the journal a lot might
have been in the son back
then we had more papers you know this is
around it was risk is it Oh was it okay
that's right you're from you're from
Green Bay I forgot about that a way of
yeah and then so the last one he writes
is layer of the white work and who
here's read the layer of the way work
couldn't get my yeah so what did you
think honestly I mean I was a teenager
at the time oh I just read Jacqueline
hey I had the framing of a bronzer
that's what many of the critics sent to
you know they are people who are we were
being paid to to make sense of things
Lovecraft HP Lovecraft said it was one
of one of the worst books he's ever and
you know I I did read it for this and it
was you know it was really cool here's
here's my impressions there's a lot
going on in it and much of what's going
on doesn't really map on that well so
the other stuff that's going on it's
almost like Stoker had maybe three
novels worth of stuff and he was like I
gotta find some way to make this all fit
together and it does all fit into one
book but it it's not a coherent
narrative and it's not because he was
doing anything experimental with like
unreliable narrators or the stuff that
people do today to be to be clever or
fancy it's just it's you know you wonder
what the hell was he thinking and in
writing us and it's it's kind of funny
it's a fun story there's a lot of cool
scenes in it you know you've got this
woman who in some way is you know
clearly snake related and any intimates
that she's actually the the white worm
but it's not clear how that could help
she could shrink down to human size and
do that and mongooses attack her because
this guy has mongooses mongoose monkeys
it just happens there happens to be a
supply store that has them pammi the
countryside and and one of them is even
like a super Mongoose that is has killed
king cobras in India before so there's
that whole story going on and then
there's this this other story about you
know the air coming back from from
abroad and he's the one who he doesn't
actually use mesmerism he there's this
this battle of wills taking place within
it and there's a lot of like domination
attempts to dominate the other person
through through your will and there's
even like you know gestures that you
make to make it happen and what's that
Daler the white worm yeah there's more
to it as well you know and so so there's
there's a at one point there's an
infestation of birds across the
countryside so this guy sends up this
massive kite way into the air that
somehow the birds think that that is a
bird of prey and then you know he wants
to do experiments with lightning and
that eventually leads to the conclusion
where lightning strikes the kite blows
up the layer of the white worm and
everybody's everybody's good at that
point I guess but I mean it's and it's
quite a story and the movie of course
we're talking about this the movie has
almost nothing to do with the book it's
there is a white worm there is a woman
who is yeah snake-like
and and there is the the notion that has
tied somehow to like ancestral Roman you
know pagan rituals and stuff like that
but there's very little other yeah well
though and the limit of the book the
worm is practically immortal and there's
a lot of theorizing by Stoker about how
beasts from the antediluvian age would
be able to like
survive on in in rare instances and
adapt themselves so that they would
continue on into our you know modern
scientific presence and how much do you
think that ties into walk now because oh
well oculus isn't in Scotland well but
he spent time in Scotland on vacation
later on yeah yeah yeah and it is the
last book that he wrote you have to
wonder with the white worm yeah well
this is happening though now that's
genetic down in England I know I know I
mean you have to wonder yeah it's an
inspiration from that legend
maybe story yeah I mean he has a story
that actually has said in Scotland in
that Dracula's guests and other stories
that was released by his wife after he
died
good luck Ness ties in to end oblivion
creatures yeah yes and all sorts of
theorize about it that's wonder if he
was inspired by some of that could be I
mean he sees a setting out a sort of a
larger theory about like how this could
be the case like across the world and
you know that so this is actually a good
part to move into the world building
right what is what is the world of
Stoker's stories like clearly it's one
in which modern progress has taken place
at least in some places like you know
the British and their empire this story
could not have taken place because it's
all done in Telegraph's and you know
what are supposed to be typewritten
copies of people's Diaries and letters
and things like that it couldn't
possibly occur without a network of
communications that we we know is
typically modern happening people are
like constantly you know mailing for
this and that the Dracula himself has
Harker Mail off some some letters saying
everything's okay here you know
don't don't wait up for me basically you
know don't worry about me and has them
posted so there's that going on right
and and they they're able to do a lot of
quite interesting things in that
perspective and yet it's also a world in
which horrible beings have managed to
survive through the centuries and could
could come to threaten that that that
very New World Order and who knows
what's lurking in all the little areas
and and some you know it's it's mummies
that are going to come back to life of
Egyptian Empress's and you know there's
all sorts of bogey
you know bogeyman that that can come out
and so and and Stoker likes to Stoker
likes to see if you can possibly connect
this with science as he understood it in
his time in anyway so you know hypnotism
mesmerism plays a role in a lot of this
he's got theories expressed about what
might be going on with Count Dracula how
he survives through the years and yet
he'll have all sorts of other things
that are life they strike you as almost
like the rank is superstition you know
we're like well you take a little bit of
the host and the wafer and you put it
around you've got a circle that'll keep
a vampire in there they research
whatever literature they can find about
how you kill these vampires and it's
similar with with all the other books
including layer the white worm you know
what do you do when you've got a giant
worm that every once in a while comes
out and wreaks havoc
well you'd opt you know mechanical thing
bringing a bunch of sand and pour that
down the wormhole and then drop some
dynamite in there that'll take care of
the problem for you you know so there
there's there's there's this weird mix
right and then the world is a foreign
world to us because it's the world of
you know the the late 19th and the early
20th century
and it's a weird 18th in late 19th and
20th century right it's a it's one in
which gothic horror can can not just
take place but perhaps you might say be
the norm be the governing principles for
four things I mean the rest of you
who've read Dracula what else would you
say about the the world that he's
building here in terms of the narrative
universe that we're in well it's
interesting because he's like it feels
like such a you know gasps like gothic
horror zones but yeah somebody brought
up like for its time it would have been
received as kind of almost like a modern
technical Oh technology blood
transfusions that's true having it on
photographic cylinders and things like
that it for its time had a bit more of
that kind of like fast-paced almost like
sort of a a Tom Clancy aspect to it up
you know people using like modern
technology I got like the like you were
saying with the epistolary aspect and
letters back and forth and you know
solicitors yeah doing business and
everything like that I think it would
have felt a lot more to the people who
are reading it at the time like this is
kind of you know something from this old
world encountering like cutting-edge
technology do you think that like the
blood transfusion thing when I when I
was you know reading that I was like boy
that was really iffy what if they what
if the blood types didn't match you know
you know I something died right well and
so well so that's what I was thinking is
is it Stoker treating this this
cutting-edge technology the way that
sometimes sci-fi authors do think about
like what everybody was doing with the
internet back in the 90s and the movies
that came out about it and now we look
at me like wow that was really awful
they how far off base were they about
about that is Stoker doing something
like that is supposed to be one of the
most accredited doctors on the planet
well we'll make these scientific
pronunciations but make no sense at all
yeah so yeah I would say very much so
again Italy in the way of like a lot of
like modern techno thrillers for people
you know yes they hacked all our Nets
our net Superman
yeah it does feel that way okay so what
else do we say about this world that
we've got is I mean something that does
occur in an Eastern Europe that Stoker
never experienced himself as far as we
know son it strikes me as a friction
between ancient world and modern world
yeah that's definitely true because
Dracula is definitely ancient yeah and
all of his beliefs and all of the things
that he grew up with yeah I lived
through you know though that's that's
one of the themes that I had wanted to
it's the very delusion into so there
that that's right and there is there's
definitely a contrast that's drawn in
there about that and they talk about his
and Helsing talks about it in terms of
his child's brain that he you know he's
not he's not fully developed the way
that we you know English people are we
have mature brains and we and that gives
them an advantage of that they can do
philosophy in the sense of like
reasoning out causes and effects which
which there's there's a couple
interesting examples of that where Van
Helsing has Seward and he's like okay so
you observe this what follows from that
and it's basically like they're doing
logic puzzles right and then they also
talk about their ability to combine in a
way that the vampires can can't but they
they're they're also concerned with the
fact that this undead curse could now
that know that Dracula's in London
because London is effectively the center
of the world
you know the communication network if
Dracula can get a foothold there then he
can spread this this vampirism all over
the world and they also hint that what
we wanted his is nip this in the bud
before he can start to truly understand
what a great threat he poses that his
his child's brain is now starting to
like work and realize that he could in
fact become mature and then who knows
think maybe they take over all of the
world and Dracula as Harker a bunch of
these pointed really all these questions
about that's true I have a whole bunch
of different solicitors doing different
things so no one would know exactly
what's right yeah yeah so that's that's
yeah he's figuring things out and and
then Helsing realizes that that's why
this one vampire is so troublesome
that's a very angle centric yeah
England the Empire British Empire is
better than everything else
Eastern European people are just
children even French you had friendship
yo yeah they're all they're all just
these Lydia fights [ __ ] of this yeah
you know some people talk about Dracula
as being trying to remember the name of
it something something Imperial genre
and the idea is that the Empire itself
is being threatened by forces that could
undermine it and that would be basically
the end of
except for maybe the Americans would
stoker did have a lot of hopes for the
Americans in park is he he was so happy
that the Irish people were over here and
and you know many of them didn't just
like stay in Boston or places like that
they became they became Cowboys you know
a lot of none of the people that we
think of as you know the Western heroes
they would be English or Scots or Irish
or you know whatever some of them were
former Confederates too and they would
just happened to be out there and so
you've got that one character who is
that archetype who of course has to die
in the end giving his life you know in a
heroic way you think the kid gets named
after him I forget it I forget what what
was named Quincy that's right so you
know hit Winchester rifles but you came
to bury that's right yeah yes I get
modern technology is it's going to
overcome Peas
yeah that'll take care of those wolves
for them but but the idea is that the
Empire can't fully understand the
threats posed to it it's it's thing it's
been too successful in a way you know so
I again I don't remember the name of the
genre but apparently there's a genre of
literature that that kids that that's
the defining trait of it well what what
other what other things really came home
to you in this I have some other themes
that I'll bring up but what else do you
know does that perfect example of like
there's an example an idea it's become a
cliche now but that our nation kind of
gave up how to do suspense where you
have people talk about baseball for ten
minutes and their bomb goes off
ten minutes of boredom followed by ten
seconds
shock well show the conversation again
and show the viewer of the bomb under
the table and this conversation which
should be banana now contain suspense
yeah and Stoker starts off his novel you
know with Dracula's castle and in
Jonathan Harker going to the sword
you'll see you know the monsters out
there and so then through like all these
sorts somewhat kind of banal epistolary
bits they come after this you know the
people are just going about living their
lives and then like there are little
things going on in the background but
you know the monsters coming yeah so
it's sort of seeping slowly like smoke
into the background well these people
are just going about you know well Lucy
westenra's getting married and Mina's
you know going about her do you have the
sense of something building behind the
scenes yeah and Seward especially his
tires
what's going on with we're dreadful and
like you know of course because of how
it connects to what you've seen but yeah
everyone else it's like this slow
dawning sense that something's wrong
first though does the album a lot of his
later novels were actually romances or
like rope yeah you can kind of see some
of that especially in the Lucy chapters
he doesn't look lair for writing
characters who are in love with each
other or who love each other there's
like a really strong bond between the
entire group that's true yeah you know
there's there's another interesting
button as well so you know this is told
through through multiple points of view
it and it is called an epistolary novel
but it's it's it's not an epistolary
novel in the same way that some others
are because there's so many different
genres of reported speech you could say
right there's there's there's telegrams
there's reports there's diary entries
that's right newspaper clippings letters
all these sorts of things and there's
there's a one passage that I wanted
to highlight and I dog you I shouldn't
dog your books but I did and this is him
dr. Seward's diary and it's talking
about how Mina Harker is she's got a
typewriter so she's she's typing
everybody's stuff out right and here we
go so he says I was so absorbed in that
wonderful diary of Jonathan Harker and
that other of his wife I'd let time run
on without thinking mrs. Harker was not
down when the maid came running to
announce dinner so I said she's possibly
tired left dinner wait an hour and I
went on with my work I just finished
mrs. mrs. Harker's diary when she came
in she looked sweetly pretty but very
sad
her eyes were flushed with crying this
somehow moved me very much of late I
have cause for tears God knows but the
relief of them was denied me and now the
sight of those sweet eyes bright with
recent tears went straight to my heart
so I said as gently as I could I greatly
fear I have distressed you
oh no not to stress me she replied but I
have been much I've been more touched
than I can say by your grief that is a
wonderful machine but it is cruelly true
it is told me in its very tones and the
anguish of your heart it was like a soul
crying out to Almighty God and then she
says no one must hear them spoken ever
again see I have tried to be useful I'd
copied out the words on my typewriter
and none other need now hear your
heartbeat as I did none ever need ever
know no one need ever know she'll ever
know I said in a low voice she laid her
hand on mine and said very gravely ah
but they must must but why I asked
because it is part of the terrible story
a part of poor dear Lucy's death and all
that led to it because in the struggle
which we have before us to rid the earth
of this terrible monster we must have
all of the knowledge and all the help
that we can get I think that the
cylinders which you gave me contained
more than you intended me to know but I
can see that there are in your record
many lights to this dark mystery you
will let me help will you not I know it
all up to a certain point and I see
already though your diary only took me
up to 7 December how poor Lucy was beset
and how our terrible doom was being run
out so some of the stuff that yours is
talking about
Professor van Helsing sauce or Jonathan
and I've been working day and night
since professor van Helsing sauce he's
gone to Whitby to get me more
information no here's the clincher we
should we need to have no secrets among
us working together and with absolute
trust we could be stronger than if some
of us were in the dark and so what she's
doing is she's she's assembling the
story all you know at the very end
there's there's this well you know we
don't have the original document so I
don't know if anyone will really believe
this but but Mina is the one who's
putting this all together and they're
putting it together because it's an
intelligence report so that they can
kill the Beast so that they can take on
the enemy so it's it's both serving the
purpose of putting together this
wonderful story now they all actually
are on the same page literally
understanding how to do things none of
them are in the dark they're reading
each other's things precisely because
she can she can take the short hand and
type it out and they can read each
other's things it's a holy crap
there was a vampire why didn't I realize
this you know and now they can all kill
it together including her who's affected
with vampirism you know so I think
that's that that you know you'd say
that's a philosophical theme this these
perspectives being warm woven into a a
story a map being dramatically depicted
in the very story itself pretty
ingenious what do you think about it for
Stoker to arrange things that way I
don't think he hit on that just by
chance
yeah almost like a disease yeah she's
afflicted with vampirism yeah and she's
gonna get worse and worse and start to
like lose sight of herself and become
cruel her eyes will get hard
yeah yeah you and and you can I suppose
your amount of will would affect it one
way or the other but once you're once
you've consumed the vampire's blood
which is how it happens in this case
you're kind of screwed you know there's
not much you can do other than you know
get rid of that vampire just like in all
the movies that you know we see with the
vampires Kelo kill the one super vampire
and they all you know either diary yeah
or a turn of Doster I you know I've seen
like like you all to get yeah so I tried
to put myself back into that time frame
never having seen anything and then
reading this and it was acusa it was
really kind of like a horror thriller I
mean it was that it was that Victorian
Gothic you're and you have to think of
Victorian times all that repression and
everything yeah this was very seductive
you know German
Dracula is a seductive character he is
even with this you know blood sucking
kind of nonsense and in just just no but
I mean it's a seduction did the way he
comes in and it is that's true he
doesn't just come out and bite you know
yeah but again you know contrasting that
with the time of the Victorian you know
all that repression everything we're not
at that time and then just like I said
when when her cruise sees him just
crawling down the wall and you know he's
kind of upside down
yeah the cape is flapping out yeah and
he's like I heard they call [ __ ] yeah I
mean what is this he's had this
harrowing experience getting there he's
already thinking something's up and then
he sees this and then all of this you
know stuff that's taking place if I had
not known any of these other things
reading this at that time would have
been really really frightening you know
some of the critics actually said like
don't let kids take a look at this book
or don't read it in the dark or things
like that well there's there's some
very racy elements to it oh yeah but
they go three women exactly
yeah are you talking about his sort of
being up you know
two minds at the same time when they're
talking about you know a few sting on
his blog where he can't wait for them to
do it even though you know he's also
terrified and knows that something
monstrous is happening in the sword he's
talking about his own essentially lust
for this thing to happen but they're
looking these women and their beautiful
lips and their rare skin and he goes on
and on and on and you know they're all
coming for him and you know he's you
know he what does how does he say he's
not like I'm a man I mean it's something
like that you know I can't going on here
but you know for this again putting
myself into the times I thought wow this
would have been really Rea something
well not just recently really for a just
frightening um so the experience of
reading it would have been quite
effective well I mean that little
concrete area what era was all full of
area was full of both stories and tales
I mean that yeah I know from my history
I mean it's it's it was nothing but
werewolves and vampires saying that was
the tales that were told all the time so
he really picked up on that well do you
think he was influenced by Jack the
Ripper read that that's what I was later
it was like 1880 yeah there isn't there
is a connection was research in 1890
yeah and there's a different kind of
kind of there were there are a lot of
things being written by English people
in that that era that gave us sort of
the repertoire of weird or horror
characters I like dr. Jekyll and mr.
Hyde is around the same time
Dorian Gray the the you know Oscar
Wilde's piece and had there been like a
penny dreadful novel Varney the vampire
that it comes yes yeah what's up I don't
know that was around the same time yeah
I mean the idea of blood sucking beasts
you know that are walking in human flesh
is scented a really new one and it's you
find out with all these different
cultures that are not connected with
each other I I haven't read the
annotated version as has anyone said
like why specifically because if you if
it wasn't over if you read what
Dracula says to Harker you know early on
yeah when they're meeting it's implied
that he actually is Vlad the third yeah
like that woman that I mean is there any
particular reason why Stoker chose that
historical person yeah well you know the
case the gear enduring this is he says
at one point stuff about himself
that's attributing it to his ancestor
and then it's a van Helsing who says you
know that that he must have been this
and that and that that the character
that he was at when times were
courageous and fought against the Turks
and was very very intelligent and
studied alchemy and stuff like that and
so the idea you know seems to be like
somehow he came upon something that
allowed him to become this you know not
that he was this always on the start but
that is this is like sort of like this
is gonna help me fight the Turks better
or something along those what's up
that will school the Transylvania
folktale about like take seven students
someone got sacked
I don't think dancer that's okay there
was a sort of conversation elements is
pretty rarely known outside of
Transylvania except among Dracula fans
trust exactly the other word I mean
there were things like that not just
there was a big fear yeah yeah yeah well
I think that find interesting I was just
thinking because I read a fair amount of
vampire literature that's right yeah and
more contemporary than right
alliteration err why and rice and
chelsea quinn Yarborough okay and there
are some others yeah more contemporary
vampires discovery which is but
different hardness they're far more
intelligent and far more urbane I've
done the human beings are there yeah
yeah well and there's they're treated
more as another race that's true yeah
less a monster yeah and they're seen as
monsters by people outside but as
character that that happens to in the
vampire movies TV shows another creature
there was that one that was that was
airing for quite a long time True Blood
right one without there there they are
like a whole different like society and
races stuff they were society is
actually I guess been Buffy the Vampire
Slayer they were as well though that's
more or less from the side of let's get
rid of these things and there is all
sorts of other stuff mixed in there as
well yeah yeah yeah well yeah actually I
mean she she fell in love with one for a
while right but it was it's a shift yeah
these are terrible monsters these are
playing along with them play you know to
some people see them as a play a show
maybe there's some other thing going on
here in terms of Amina a creature of
their own a species yeah those the
historian but kind of a retelling go
away again at a lengthy if that actual
flat the third had survived into modern
day where it's almost treated as a kind
of a secret society okay people wore in
on some kind of secret there was a there
was a British show there was a British
show I think it might have been called
ultraviolet or something Iran is typical
British show like six episodes run and
it came out in the early 2000s same sort
of story like vampires you know versus
humans and they're they're you know
they're their own thing and what's not
you know wipe them out but then of
course it turns out they're bad and they
are trying to take over one that I
thought was actually quite interesting
and successful in doing the let's draw
this out in suspense that's a recent
show I don't know if any of you know is
the strain have any of you seen Alan so
I think they had about four series four
I for four seasons sorry
and it starts out fairly slow vampirism
is transmitted through these worms that
like get into people and and make people
immortal but also kind of deform them
and its really a parasite that that
lives in you takes over the body and and
they're and they're portrayed for a
while as you know why are you
persecuting us that sort of thing well
long term that's Anne Rice's theory yeah
as a parasite oh is it was a spirit of
some kind a spirit of some kind but it's
also treated like it's parasitic on
okay way into you know way into the
inner series yeah let's talk about it
being a parasitic spiritual or viral
kind of thing but I guess in this
there's really never any real
explanation about what what vampirism is
or what caught what the underlying
condition is you know it's just a
symptom ology your teeth get longer your
eyes get hard pretty soon you know you
don't like the Sun anymore start needing
dirt but a little lot of compensating
things you know you can control the
elements be a bath be a wolf what else
could he be in forever yeah rat yeah
could be a mist live forever although
you know that live for everything that's
that's another interesting theme that
doesn't really get treated in this but
does get treated in some of that the
other literature yeah how do you not get
bored out here I mean it also comes up
so somebody put down Roger Zelazny we
did The Chronicles of amber and that's
you know that's one where you've got
immortals and they are presented with
the same problem of what do you do
you're gonna live forever about some of
these stabs you and you know well you
know just between Yarbrough books aside
your main books she what she deals with
eventually is technology okay for
generations for centuries he can get by
by changing his name and becoming his
own descendant and all of a sudden now
we have facial recognition
and fingerprints and yeah you know
Airlines you know these is up that's
like hide and he's in one of the later
story short stories he's dealing with
how do I hide it that's anonymous I
change and he comes up with this in one
of the stories I think it was set in
World War two ROM Tyler order he comes
up with this these dummies that can be
that looked like him okay that he can
get killed off in a bombing or something
and he can change this is smart way to
deal with it but as technology changes
and speaker prints and what happened
he's struggling with how do I not get
detected how did I not get discovered in
these in this new world that he's
dealing with it's a good thing you know
I just think the Highlander movies if
you remember those Australia you know
like the first one it's a good thing
that it happened in the human what 80s
or 90s yeah because they didn't have
that technology back then you know but
now now I suppose yeah they that we're
moving into a very different time yeah
I've only you're in the the first what
was the first book in interview yeah
that's how much more compliance rights
more complex
yeah you know one of the other things I
thought it'd be kinda interesting to
talk about in this that's a theme that
comes up here is they're doing things
that they know are illegal and they're
doing it to save civilization there's a
couple places or look they're like we
can't tell the cops this because they
they won't understand what's happening
so there's a sort of like vigilantism
for civilization and for for Victorian
era characters this is a moral quandary
right
Stoker actually writes in in the piece
about censorship that I was talking
about about there being an illegal laws
and then there are moral laws the moral
laws take priority over the legal laws
and yet they
our laws they you know they they apply
that they're even more rigorous and so
you've got these characters that are
doing things like van Helsing is doing
things that are essentially sacrilegious
you know he's he says at one point I
have a dispensation and then the the
person who did the annotations like
that's not the way these things work no
he says I have an indulgence and and
they're like that's not what indulgences
actually mean you wouldn't get
permission to take a consecrated host
and crumble it up put it around door
frames or stuff like that that just
doesn't work that way you know but
Stoker you know he's like yeah you have
that you know then Helsing can do that
and they have a conversation about the
propriety of doing these extra legal
things and they come to the conclusion
essentially along I guess the
utilitarian lines that this is the right
thing for us to do you know it would
just slow us down to try to explain this
to a judge or you know but they do worry
about it quite a bit that's I thought
that was quite quite interesting I feel
like the way Stoker really makes that
work is that all of his protagonists who
band together to fight triangle are all
extremely morally up yes yes yeah
there's no slouching where no one's
trying to like profit on the side
somehow from this war or is like the
sort of person who might do something
out of cruelty they're they're all very
certain in their morality is what makes
it okay when they make these decisions
to act outside the law it's you know
that these are you or at least you're
told over and over again these are
people who you know if they make a
formal decision it's going to be the
right one yeah one of the commentaries I
read suggested that there was a
homosexual theme within Dracula I didn't
see it but they suggested that there's a
lot a lot of speculation yeah that
Stoker was actually homosexual so I
think I've been too wild yeah I think
that there were I think that those are
like two different issues that we could
deal with separately
I mean it does look like like it doesn't
look like it's like Stoker had any
interest in homosexual activity but he
did have very strong friendships that
that certainly seemed to be erotic in
some sense you know and and
interestingly when Wilde was convicted
and he spoke for himself at his trial he
thought he was going to help himself out
he actually like got got them totally
against him he's like bringing up well
you know play those time there were
these you know read the symposium there
are these beautiful relationships and
they're not sexual at all between men
and they're you know they they
understand that men can be lovers and
all they heard there was like this yeah
and I think that you know I think
arguably I mean you look at the people
who stalker was really into wild Whitman
and this guy
Irving now Irving was was pretty he
looked like he was pretty heterosexual
he had had a leading lady that you know
he put in all his plays and he but you
know it looks like he may have married
somebody to be what we nowadays call a
beard yeah the very oh it sounds like
some repression there so that's probably
that was the speculation so that's
probably the case the question that is
are there any of these elements in in
Dracula I don't see it either I didn't
see it I think you'd have to like
deliberately read it in in ways that
would be not in a sexual way but in a
literate way perverse so it's a find it
in there but I might be wrong you know I
don't know I I don't think you know
sexual so if there's any of it
yeah and maybe this is more of a
convention at the time but like I do
notice how often and to what extent you
know all the characters in Dracul all
their protagonists you know tell each
other how much they love and respect one
another and how close they feel to one
that's true and they and they also
complement each other quite a bit for
their manliness there is this aspect of
[Music]
not arrows but like I got off in between
everybody like oh yeah all of our
protagonists really seem to love and
respect one another like you said well
we'll complement each other's manliness
or yeah brightness or you know in a way
that you just don't see in love until
they spoke you know Lucy is also an
erotic object in there who manages to
bring the men together right because
you've got the two failed suitors and
then the one who actually does get to
marry her right they all give their
blood there's actually that that seemed
to or they're like the one guy is saying
well I consider us married because I
gave my my blood so you know I tried to
help you out and all that and then it
was a fat healthy person as men Helsing
are both coloring the back as they know
they did the same thing yeah that's
right I forgot about that yeah yeah
that's sunny in effect maybe she does
right does van Helsing give his blood I
don't and Seward actually says something
along the lines that maybe this is kind
of like that competition for Lucy's
affection because he says something
online lines like well you took a lot
more blood from Arthur Holmwood
you know he was giving with weight he
was he was her husband in your nod or
something along that's right yeah yes I
mean I mean with homosexuality which
Stoker's marriage with his wife which
was not completely just a child yeah
yeah it's a it's not quite what you
would call a mariage blush which means
an unconsummated marriage that was kind
of a popular thing for her for quite a
few people but you know they probably
the consummation was probably like well
you know gotta do your duty otherwise
they're probably I mean clearly they
they you know they were fertile so if
they wanted more kids they would have
had more kids it doesn't say any babies
were stillborn or anything like that so
maybe once they had one child that was
all that they thought needed I don't
really know that much about his wife
frankly whether she was happy or not or
anything like that
[Music]
history I don't know I mean depending on
the woman yeah you know yeah they're
quite a few and actresses were already
sort of on the weird end of society
anyway they weren't the they hadn't been
given the legitimacy that they now have
in our you know in our times when it's
actually more social currency to be an
actress
back then you were kind of disreputable
still it wasn't like it's
as it was say the Middle Ages or the
Renaissance but they still weren't
completely accepted in society one other
thing I did want to bring up to is
Stoker
you know Stoker studied philosophy and
he doesn't have his characters talk like
philosophers at quite a few points I
mentioned they like let's run through
the problem you know step by step by
step he is you know sort of like what
goes on with with Arthur Conan Doyle and
Sherlock Holmes there are these long
processes of inference and and they're
actually I don't find them boring to
read myself or so I listened to it on
tape as well I don't find it boring to
do that but I teach philosophy for a
living so I was kind of curious those of
you who read through those passages were
you like I got a skip ad or I really
like oh this is an integral part of the
the unfolding and the the plot because
in movies they don't through that
anymore they let's skip ahead you know
that guy's a vampire you know we don't
we don't have these long laborious
chains of inference going on you know it
was kind of interesting is when Renfrew
was that philosopher that's true when he
got about a blue city and that's right
he's started going into this whole
philosophical treatise then the guys are
all looking like whoa I mean that was a
huge passage of what he went on and on
and that is not the character that you'd
ever see in the movies like the you know
the spider eating weird of us climbing
the walls this this character in here
the original character was much more
rich I mean he I mean he had he had a
whole lot more going for there's a
tragic figure
he was absolutely a tragic figure yeah
and but but there's a big passage in
there where he's going through with this
philosophical you know humor each time a
life and how you have to consume it and
well answer that but other things too
because the guys are all there you know
the little the little crew is there and
they're like whoa and then they
they started to engage we're
philosophically and his Seward was you
know if you think about the vampire
movies
Renfield has generally turned into this
this sort of caricature reading claim
the walls kind of guy and and he was and
he was I mean he had his moments where
he had to be straight check you know
when he when the man I was near and
stuff by me and you know van helsing
types keep showing up in movies right
the sort of sage vampire hunter who
knows the the answers again you like in
the strain he was he was the old guy in
the strain who fights fights the
vampires played by the same same guy the
same actor who played the Frey patriarch
and the Game of Thrones thing that's
kind of weird to see it was a good guy
that's true yeah yeah but I mean we have
we definitely have rent filled
characters we definitely have been
Helsing characters I guess you could say
that we do have Quincey characters the
sort of tough guy you know who's gonna
kill the vampires and a lot of vampire
movies sometimes it just reduces to that
there's no man he'll so there's just you
know some tough guy doing that do we
have the other types of characters in
which case in which case she's not Mina
she's she's actually Quincey right no
shorthand and things to collect the
stories and gather yeah there's a great
example of that and this is kind of
tangential
yeah if you've ever read any of the Alan
Moore wrote a comic book of the League
of Extraordinary Gentlemen yeah like I'm
coming to that concordance of various
novels and stories in and the head of
the group is is Mina well she she had
been divorced to become Mina Murray
again
oh the comics in the comics she's just a
very resourceful very forthright
intelligent person who can bring
everyone together but then when they had
to make a movie out of it they decided
well dropping her out she's got to be no
they don't but they shouldn't they meet
her like half a vampire so now she can
do all the cool Dracula stuff okay
basically do the cool I guess I don't
remember that movie though yeah they
made her superhero a vampire superheroes
yes yes she was basically okay I don't
know if you're supposed to be half
vampire would but it wasn't enough for
her to just be anyway for a source well
yeah I bring people she had to have
powers okay yeah do we have anybody
who's like Seward in contemporary
vampire movies penny dreadful actually
has character who was literally super
but she was a female that's right yeah
it wasn't interesting I don't remember
much about that I don't like her much
the penny dreadful it was more concepts
than exit yeah yeah that's true
we watched our way through that but we
were not particularly impressed there
were so many points where we were like
well there's so many points we were like
that should have been written like this
because then they could have done this
and they sort of wrote themselves into
boxes
Ethan literally the cowboy yes he really
is like a what if Quincey Morris but
we'll make him a bit more effective yeah
yeah yeah okay you know there was
another thing too that they I think if I
remember this book has like a listing of
all the different Dracula movies yeah it
does all the different adaptations of it
so many of them and I remember like you
know seeing some of the more recent ones
and thinking those weren't that good you
know it's tough to find good adaptations
of of that and maybe it maybe it's not
something that really loves it would
lend itself well to a movie and maybe
something that would have to be done
with like a streaming series but it's
hard to see how you could get a producer
to be willing to take it as slow as this
part yeah the the series seems to be
like the format that would fit best
because there's a slow burn for most of
them yeah its atmospheric it's trying to
slowly build up this sense of something
going wrong and now that audiences think
they know it they might not it's true
maybe maybe a kiss maybe it's been done
so many times you can't really do
something of this work with it anymore I
don't know I mean it's it's interesting
because we now have were you know in the
past I guess the movie was sort of like
the nothing parks a loss and TV shows
are seeing be they're seen as like being
not as good yeah and but now there's
more potential I mean you think about
some of the good sci-fi speculative
fiction series that are out there in the
present West world for example the
adaptation
dicks man in the high castle which
granted there way off book at this point
but it's pretty good stuff you know
there's so much more that you can do in
that that format and it's different than
TV used to be when we were younger where
show came on once a week and they shot
it you know maybe in advance or maybe
you know that week hey and that was what
you got well you know the ability to put
out a show it's entire season all at
once for somebody to binge watch yeah
well you don't have to have everybody
remember okay what happened last weekend
ever world yeah you don't have to do the
three-minute recap at the beginning is
to have to do you know you can have an
episode of a show which doesn't
necessarily have like that beginning
middle and an end in the same way that
it would have done saved back in the 90s
where each episode had to be sort of
self-contained even if it had an overall
arc to it yeah that's that's quite true
and it's funny to watch old old shows
which now don't seem quite as good in
comparison maybe we've actually landed
as a totally outside of the realm of
this but maybe we've actually landed on
a jean row which is in some respects
superior to the other visual genres that
we had available before I don't know I
think that's true yeah and movies can go
straight to TV no without without
without being seen as yeah without being
seen as like oh well it's one of those
kind of just two DVD kind of movies
right yeah as a matter of fact Netflix
in order to try to win Academy Awards
had to find some theaters where they
could like play one one viewing of some
of their movies qualified yeah Scorsese
or somebody was talking about wanted
- called the Irishman or something along
those lines okay and so he went to like
every major studio every major movie
studio with his idea and none of them
were interested in it and I think he was
approached by one of Amazon or Netflix
or somebody who gave 100 million dollars
and said make the movie your way okay
Netflix because they're showing it at
the theater for the [ __ ] and then it's
going to nibble I complained about that
the theaters wanted it for longer has a
contract OMG this is the one where I'm
DeNiro initiative that they're all made
to look younger and stuff you know buy
some CDs I'm gonna say something really
man thank you can they give dinero back
his talent I think he's I mean Pesci is
but I was talking about this in class
with some of my students today you know
they're talking about there was a film
class right before my class and and
there's one kid who is in both classes
and so the teacher was there and I said
what are what are you guys talking about
is 1000 we're gonna see the Graduate
it's all that's that's that's pretty
cool and I said did you tell you about
like the ending and he's like don't tell
me about it I haven't seen it yet and so
you know I was like yeah it was really
kind of interesting to see it I mean you
think about Dustin Hoffman now and you
look at him when he was so young and
they were talking about seeing Clint
Eastwood when Clint Eastwood was really
cuz he only knows Clint Eastwood as this
super super old guy who's famous for
like talking to the chairs as being
Obama and things like that that's what
his generation yeah and and then we're
talking about other actors yeah somebody
you know like Hoffman Hoffman so a good
actor you know and Eastwood I don't know
haven't seen him lately but things he
did ten years ago he's still acting
pretty well but then I was like yeah and
some actors you know De Niro Pacino
they were really great once and now you
know with roll back in the Irishman
are they on the same damn thing mrs.
Gurley's do I mean it's the same yeah
been here seen that I think that's why
it's getting the Netflix order of course
say they can get a better performance
out of them though then somebody else
would be able to do nothing
yeah I talked about film success yeah
there was just an article I read about
Hallmark Christmas movies and why they
are so successful yeah because it's the
same formula over and also a percent of
American actors yeah the male leads
what is it the models that they hired
yeah oh really
yeah but the majority were hired just
because they were good-looking but they
are talking about why they're so
successful compared to other television
stations that tried to do something so
like lifetime for example like lifetime
erm is because people like to have happy
ending
yeah they film them in three weeks has
been no more than two million dollars
per film okay and they can churn about
the total escape reserve their total
escape near their total positive escape
it you know it's like the glue is there
like the pulp of the time nobody knows
there are formula everybody knows it's
gonna not be ending but because they can
turn them out at under two million
dollars a piece
yeah the actors that don't get paid a
huge amount of money and people just
love them and they're extremely
successful in here right you know what
they run the speciality something
also do direct because it's the same
formula you have to clean up the same
story formula but you have to write them
quick active quick be competent but not
too confident be inexpensive I'm gonna
make a show after this crosses over see
we're serious good a few who cross over
well interesting but it was you and you
know what success in film it was you
know you could there's there been so
many to come to rate back to Stoker
Dracula been so many vampires things
that at this point you could you could
probably turn out like vampire formulaic
story after story you could probably
have a channel to that you know
certainly sort of like that at one time
they they they proposed having a
law-and-order channel I don't think they
ever pulled it off but there's enough
content out there that you could easily
fill up the airwaves with a cable
channel that would just play lon is it
really okay well you could probably do
that with vampire stuff I imagine
maybe there is some such a thing I don't
know I haven't looked
I don't watch enough TV which is
Twilight Zone Outer Limits so
speculative and sci-fi keeps churning
out their stuff so much of it of uneven
quality but you know
yeah well what else is there to say
about about Dracula before we close them
anything else well you were asking like
you know do we get like a dr. Seward
figure in oh yeah adaptations well one
thing I was thinking about with and I
mean Stoker doesn't really good job with
like the Jonathan Harker character it
reminds me of something else we're
talking about only one of the reasons
why in many films especially like
adventure or SF films like you're your
primary protagonist is a looping on the
bland side a lot of the time yeah some
of the people around like the reason why
Luke Skywalker's a little bit less
interesting - Han Solo for instance is
because a you as the viewer are meant to
preserve and protect yourself onto them
okay that's your point of view character
that's the person you could sort of see
yourself being and so they aren't
supposed to have too many personality
quirks or be too kind of uniquely either
because then they don't feel like
somebody you could be any more they feel
like themselves yeah I feel like
Jonathan Harker kind of fills that hole
in Dracula where it's sort of like you
are you know that you are Jonathan
Harker experiencing and you know what
makes Jonathan Parker Jonathan Harker's
he's been a victim because he was a
victim yeah we can always do scantily
clad women freaking being menaced by
Dracula but ready the male victim is
still challenging interesting yes I
suppose so yeah okay well that's a good
place to end this so thanks everybody
for coming
good conversation
[Music]
you